this is Monsanto's round it can cookies
bread corn crackers chips stretch the
cereal and beer the list goes on and on
and on the active ingredient in roundup
is called glyphosate and it's used by
backyard gardeners and industrial
farmers alike to kill invasive weeds and
weather glyphosate is harmful to humans
or not is something of a sixty six
billion dollar question but first what
is glyphosate there's never been a
herbicide like it before
glyphosate was originally introduced in
1974 by Monsanto Houston American
agriculture has soared nearly tenfold
since Monsanto introduced the first
genetically modified Roundup Ready seeds
in 1996 glyphosate has now used in more
than 160 countries with more than 1.4
billion pounds applied per year and
while Monsanto lost patent protection
over glyphosate herbicides in 2000 the
company still has about 40% of the eight
billion dollar global herbicide market
because of what is called the quote
virtuous cycle
Monsanto sells its genetically modified
Roundup Ready seeds to produce cotton
corn and other commodities to make them
resistant to glyphosate herbicide will
effects more sales of the GMO seeds
beget more use of roundup more herbicide
use drives up demand from Monsanto's GMO
seeds for 25 years that cycles enjoyed
an unblemished run in our crops soil and
food until now
now Monsanto has its own invasive
species creeping in doubt on its website
Monsanto says glyphosate is about half
as toxic as table salt the more than 25
times less toxic than caffeine more than
a thousand farmers and herbicide
applicators stricken with non-hodgkins
lymphoma disagree hundreds of plaintiffs
with cancer have filed a class-action
lawsuit against the company in 2015 the
International Agency for research on
cancer known as IARC determined
glyphosate to be a probable carcinogen
remem
at 66 billion dollars that's where this
comes in it's how much bear is offering
to buy Monsanto for but if glyphosate is
thought of as cancer-causing and made
back out of the deal completely but what
would life without glad to sate look
like according to Bloomberg agriculture
expert Christopher Perella it wouldn't
be pretty
the alternative would be a step back and
it would definitely affect farmers
income the profitability the way they do
business
eventually filters down on the consumer
in terms of higher prices for meats for
for all all food products the question
now after the EPA's own hand-picked
experts have also voiced concerns is
what the Trump EPA will do about it but
with administration's from Clinton to
Bush to Obama promoting GMOs it seems
unlikely Trump's EPA will be any
different
you